- On this episode, I talk about gratitude,
why I love to climb and not jets,
and kids with technology.
(upbeat music)
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep trying to answer.
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and you're watching the #AskGaryVee Show.
Episode number 24.
Fun fact about the number 24,
that is worn by Darrelle Revis,
former Jets great,
now piece of crap, trader
Patriot Darrelle Revis.
- [Voiceover] Oxygen Beats asks,
"Which hurts your credibility more:
having no popularity, or
faking your popularity?
Thoughts on fake views?"
Oxygen clearly in a world now
where it's much more transparent
and people can dig.
And it's not just,
20/20 has exposed you, Steve,
what do you say about your fake views?
- I don't know.
- Ya know, that world,
where it'd happen once
in a while, is over.
Now we live in a TMZ kind of world.
Bloggers, Gawker, like, faking
it is such a dangerous thing.
I mean, what hurts your
credibility is the lying.
It's amazing what people can actually
get away with it in our society
if they own it.
We don't care about the adultery.
We don't care about the faking it.
We care about when you're exposed,
you lying about it.
It's nuts, it's an interesting psychology,
especially here in the States.
More so than, maybe,
other parts of the world.
To me it's basically faking it.
And more importantly, like,
what about sleeping at night?
Ya know, like, it's kinda
fun to sleep at night.
Especially today, I'm under the weather,
by the way, everybody.
So if my energy level
is a little bit lower,
I apologize.
- [Voiceover] Young Entrepreneur asks,
"Would you ever automate your position,
delegate to as many people as it takes,
and spend 95% of your time fully engaged
in family and life?"
- Absolutely not.
And as a young entrepreneur,
Young Entrepreneur, let
me tell you something
from Old Entrepreneur.
Which is, I love the process of the work.
I love the grind.
I love the climb.
You know, I love the idea of
getting to buying the Jets,
more so than buying the Jets.
It's the process.
To delegate out what I love,
would defeat the purpose.
Of course, I wanna spend as much time
with my family, as possible.
But that would be lying to my soul
if I didn't do what I wanna do.
And what I want to do for a living is
build organizations, build companies,
create commerce, be a salesman,
be a guidance counselor, HR character,
social commentate and put out content.
I would suffocate if I
couldn't put out the work
that's needed to accomplish
the things that I want.
Psst.
The problem Young Entrepreneur,
especially when you're
a young entrepreneur,
is people want stuff, right?
They want the bling-bling here, right?
They want the cool ass kicks.
They want the car, they
want the jet, not the Jets.
They want stuff.
I don't want stuff.
I want the sweat, and the pain,
and the gratitude, and the, you know,
happiness that comes along with the work.
I want the work, I don't want the stuff.
- Hey Gary, I've got a very
simple question for you.
This is not the outfit to do it in,
so, one second.
Okay, whew.
- You're wrong, brother.
You had the right outfit on
the first time.
- [Man in suit] I have these,
occasional rushes of motivation.
It's like, yes.
Now I'm gonna do this.
But after a few days,
that motivation goes away.
So how do you get that constant
stream of motivation?
Thanks a lot.
- You know speakin',
you know, this piggybacks well off of the
last question.
Ya know, my motivation
comes from a couple places.
One, I love what I do.
You know, you may not love, again,
back to what you want.
Especially seeing a lot of the youngsters
jumping in today's show,
you may think that doing things is
the process needed to what you want,
which is you wanna be in Las Vegas
with 30 beautiful women around you,
and like, drinking
champagne and going crazy.
Like, I don't like that stuff.
No, I don't.
You know, I don't like that stuff.
I like the process.
So, you know, to me there's
two things that drive me.
One, I love what I do,
for the billionth time.
My separating aspect from a lot of you,
I'm keepin' it real,
is I love working, I
love putting in the work,
I love the headaches,
I love HR nightmares,
I love it.
I like it.
I like the grind.
I like that I have a 6:30 call today
with an upset customer.
I like that.
And so, that's number one.
Number two is straight up gratitude.
You wanna have real fuel?
I don't know what this meant.
I'm just trying to become Superman.
If you want real fuel,
that was injecting gratitude,
You want real fuel to win?
Be grateful.
Now you can't be grateful.
You can't watch this video and be like,
oh great, Gary Vee said I'm not grateful.
In me, in my personality is gratitude.
The self-awareness that I was born in the,
in the Soviet Union, that the
timing of when I was born,
was better than when my dad was born,
better than when my
grandparents were born there.
It created a scenario
where this moment in time,
where America and Israel got together,
and made a deal with the Soviet Union,
and people were able to leave the country,
and that's it.
I got really lucky that,
what I'm great at is,
is really kind of glamorized here.
Entrepreneur businessman,
whereas in Russia,
who knows, I'd probably
be dead or a trillionaire.
And so, I'm just grateful.
I'm grateful for the greatest parents
that one could ask for.
I'm grateful for, like, amazing wife.
A lot of, unfortunately, I
lost a lot of my grandparents
before I was even five.
So I haven't had a lot of death.
And so, you know, it's really like,
I don't even have a gear that's like,
woe is me or too bad.
First of all, I also
don't like complaining.
I've made this bed.
Like I feel ill today, I'm
under the weather, right?
But I'm not like, oh.
We're always like, watch this.
Here, I don't know if you can get in here.
People are gonna like this.
Let's show something of fun to everybody.
I don't know, talk to me.
Can people see the schedule?
- [DRock] Yep, they can.
- Yep, I mean, like, you know.
So schedule, right?
Like, workout at 6:30, and travel,
and meeting, and meeting, and meeting,
and speak, and call, and
speak, and tape the show,
right, and then call, and then
meeting, and then meeting,
and then meeting, and then meeting.
And if you're paying
attention to 10 minutes,
10 minutes,10 minutes,
five minutes, 15 minutes.
Planning meeting, call,
call, coffee, meeting,
meeting, meeting,
meeting, meeting, meeting,
and today's a good day,
'cause it's a Friday.
Because I get to be done, you know, by
eight o'clock, with
dinner with some friends.
But like, when you go back, you know,
I mean, the bottom line
is, I'm in meeting,
well this is Jet's game.
But, but (phone clanking against table),
I'm making my bed.
I'm making my bed, I'm going forward.
I'm hustling from six to 11 pm everyday,
with every second allocated.
There is no break.
There's no, there's no eat a salad,
and read Reddit, or watch YouTube.
That is not in my game.
Yes, Steve, that was for you.
You know that is not in my game.
And so, because I've made my bed,
I'm surely not gonna complain and be like,
oh, I'm sick today.
Like, I just, you know, no.
So that's it.
I don't even remember
what I was answering.,
but that's what I think.
(laughing)
Excellent.
- [Voiceover] Ozzy asks,
"Why is your phone always in the shot?"
- My phone is always in shot,
because my phone is always with me.
Plus, my adorable Xan's on there.
I don't want to show his pictures,
he doesn't want me to
share kid photos that much,
but the other reason is
because if you haven't heard,
this is an extension of
you as a human being.
Every one of you, rarely,
is ever, arm's length away,
from your phone in every 24 hour window,
including while you're
sleeping and showering.
This is an extension of us.
This is, ya know, eventually
it's gonna be here,
and here, and then helmet,
and then eventually, directly in us.
This is the extension point and so
it's always with me, because
I need it to be a human.
That's right.
It sounds sad.
Plenty of comments coming, like, ugh,
but that's just the way it is.
- [Voiceover] Swelldesigner asks,
"I'm curious to know
what your thoughts are
on tech consumption by young children."
- This is an interesting
one, because I've done
a lot of lucky, serendipitous piggybacking
on today's questions, because
I just went into that.
And you know, kids are
all up in this right now,
and I think it's evolution.
I mean, if you were to ask the
person that was like me
during the caveman days,
on his or her show,
what you think about humans
that look like us today,
all of you cavemen and
women would be like,
no, ugh, ugh, ugh, terrible,
but we've evolved.
And I think that children are
growing up with technology.
We are definitely going
into that futuristic world.
And I think it's great.
I think that there are going to be
different versions of us,
but that's not bad.
I'm not the dad that's gonna be like,
"Get outside and play."
Of course I want them to be healthy,
but don't forget, our kids are eating
a hell of a lot better than any of us.
All our Big Macs everyday
are a hell of a lot
different than kale chips
that we're all growing up with now.
And so there's trade offs.
Not to mention more people work out now.
So, you know, I think they're
gonna be more informational.
Listen to me, less information-smart,
because it's a commodity,
'cause anything you want
to know is here.
And I think there's just
gonna be different characters.
And so, I'm super excited about it.
I think it's uh, I think it's uh,
phenomenal.
I love that children are growing up
totally different.
I love that I see Xander
thinking everything swipes.
There's some downsides,
like everything else.
I'm worried about them being as active,
but you can, if you're a good parent,
you can do whatever you want.
But I'm not restricting
hours of a second screen,
or a third screen for my children,
because I think it's
actually prepping them
for the world that's actually gonna exist.
Straight up.
It's kind of almost like alcohol, right?
Like kids, like, wanna
drink because in America
we don't let them drink.
And so, like, you know
the kids that are gonna be
restricted to one hour a day are gonna
over-value this, and so, um,
I'm very fascinated by it, and I'm a very
go-with-the-flow kind of character.
And I'll also adjust to the reality
of how my kids adopt to it.
That is episode 24 of
the #AskGaryVee Show.
Simple question.
I'm gonna do a little right-hook on you.
Because my next meeting
I saw in the calendar is
with my Resy team.
Resy is an app that
does restaurant buying,
access to the tables, here in New York.
We'll be putting it out to other places,
but it made me think of
exactly what I wanted
to ask you today,
'cause I also still have
dinner with friends,
which is, what is your favorite restaurant
right this second?
(fingers snap)
You keep asking questions,
I will continue to answer them.
Oh crap, wait, subscribe.
(beeping)
I need subscriptions because I can't push
this many regular in social.